This is Lakhi Ram Lohar.
His job was to spray pesticide
at a tea garden in West Bengal, India.
Lakhi was a single father
to his only daughter, Sugi.
One day in 2007,
Sugi went missing.
Lakhiram went to the local police
to file a missing persons report,
but he was unable to do so
because he was illiterate.
He didn't have Sugi's birth certificate
or any of her photographs.
So, the police didn't believe him,
and did nothing.
He tried, again and again, but no luck.
It was as if Sugi never existed.
Ten years later,
a local nonprofit
that fights human trafficking
took up her case.
They approached Sugi's school
and requested proof that she had attended.
Here is the certificate, issued in 2017,
10 years after her disappearance.
It bothered me
that the disappearance of a poor girl
doesn't matter to anyone,
except her family.
I'm a photojournalist,
and I report on critical human rights
and social issues,
not just in my country, India,
but across the Global South.
I see stories like this everywhere.
One of the biggest myths
about human trafficking
is that it is a developing world problem.
But the reality is that human trafficking
is a 150-billion-dollar
industry, globally.
The International Labour
Organization's 2016 report
reveals that 40.3 million people
were trafficked into modern-day slavery,
out of which 23 million
were women and girls.
It's as if girls and women
from poor families
don't have any value,
and their existence or their deaths ...
don't matter.
Their stories are mostly
unseen and unheard.
But it's important to see these stories
and not look away.
Photographs inspire compassion
and enhance our understanding
of the world.
It is a powerful tool
for making connections with people.
But when we undertake the task
of sharing people's lives,
we have an added responsibility.
Are we representing them
with dignity and fairness?
Are we telling the whole story
or just a part of it?
I'm very conscious about stereotypes
and how I represent people.
Life can be harsh for poor girls
from these countries.
Boys are given preferential treatment,
while girls are expected
to do household chores --
cook, clean, fetch water,
and take care of their younger siblings.
Often, parents tend to marry
their daughters early
so they would become
someone else's responsibility.
Basic education is free
in many developing countries,
but students still need
to buy books and uniforms,
and when putting even two meals
on the table is a struggle,
schools can seem like a luxury.
So when I went to Nepal a few years ago,
to document child marriage
for Human Rights Watch,
I thought the girls I would meet
were forced by their parents to marry.
What I saw was a bit different.
The girls I met wanted
to escape a grim situation
and gain some control of their lives.
When Tilmaya was 11,
her father took her out of school
and sent her to Pokhara
to work as a domestic maid.
When she was 15, she eloped
and married a 20-year-old man
from her village.
This is Sharmila.
Sharmila's parents tried
to separate her from her boyfriend,
so she ran away with him.
She was 14, he was 18.
When I took this image of her,
Sharmila was seven months pregnant.
She said she regrets
leaving school and marrying early
and that she had no knowledge
of reproductive health or family planning.
So why would girls leave the safety
of their families,
drop out of school?
For nothing?
To gain some control
of their future.
At least, in this case, they were able
to choose their own partner.
I try to dig deep and show
the nuances of the situations,
because often, poor women and girls
are stripped of their equity and dignity.
I would not have taken these photographs
if the girls didn't want me to.
And I work very discreetly,
keeping a low profile,
and go to great lengths
to avoid attention.
I carry minimum gear
and this dirty-looking tote bag,
which my mother hates.
(Laughter)
The idea is to blend with the crowd.
Even if I dress simply,
it's understood I am from the city.
So I tell people I'm a researcher
into female hygiene.
I started carrying
sanitary napkins in my purse.
Men are so embarrassed,
they leave me alone.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
The women offer me tea,
and I sit and chat with them for hours,
until they get bored of me.
That's when my real work begins.
The family knows there will be no gossip
or any unwelcome scrutiny,
as I had already been
to 10 different houses.
Everyone in the village just assumes
I was there to speak about menstruation.
I'm very careful that my work
does not disrupt
the lives of the people I photograph,
while I'm there and long after I've left.
I do hours of research before diving
into a new territory,
honoring people's culture,
abiding by local laws.
Asking permission,
seeking informed consent
and not leading with my camera
has been the foundation of my work.
And this has helped me overcome
many hostile situations.
While working on a project
called "Not My Shame,"
documenting sexual violence
in my country, India,
I met a young girl I’ll call Beena.
Beena was abducted and repeatedly raped
by a distant relative.
This man was also a very powerful
person in the community.
While I was sitting
with Beena at her house,
a huge crowd had gathered outside.
Hearing loud voices, I went out,
only to be surrounded
by a group of hostile men.
The men snatched my camera bag,
tore off my purse,
and started berating me.
My first thought was to protect Beena
and her family, and also myself.
I tried to appear calm,
although I was scared.
The men said they thought I was there ...
to disrupt their lives
and spoil the village's reputation.
I told them I was there to learn
about their lives and culture.
By the end of our conversation,
an hour later,
these same men offered me tea and snacks.
Despite this incident,
Beena and her family
wanted me to share her story
with the world.
Beena’s story matters,
so does Sugi's,
and hundreds of women's
and girls' like them.
Their stories would not
have been seen or heard
if people like me didn't show them.
We need to start valuing them.
The first step to any change
is acknowledgment and awareness.
Otherwise, this cycle of harm
will continue.
These women and girls exist.
And the reason I'm telling you this
is because we were lucky enough to be born
in very comfortable circumstances.
We won the birth lottery.
These women have values.
They exist.
The least we can do is honor them
and not look away.
Thank you.
(Applause)